[Music]
before MARY POPPINS returns revisit
Disney's best live-action film of the
60s with our apologies to fans of the no
mobile the horse in the gray flannel
suit monkeys go home and the computer
wore tennis shoes Applejack
it's absolutely right Applejack
Applejack Chisholm City social club
Applejack Pompeii Palace
then how did Disney stick around long
enough to run the world they spend like
three decades making Troy McClure movies
you might remember me from such films as
Gladys the groovy mule Mary Poppins meet
Mary Poppins magic nanny and full-blown
narcissist practically perfect in every
way who never misses an opportunity to
check herself out doesn't get close to
anyone what would happen to me if I
loved all the children I said goodbye to
and creates a pocket universe of animals
to literally sing her praises but she
isn't just a sing-song Slytherin she's
also just a so-so nanny who leaves kids
alone to go on a date
drugs them before bed and gas lights
anyone who discovers her powers until
they begin to doubt their own sanity a
respectable person like me in a horse
race how dare you suggest such thing go
to sleep okay let's see egomaniac rich
going from house to house in England how
much you want to bet she works for the
Ministry of Magic too bad she got stuck
with the Weasleys follow along on Mary's
quest to bring order and happiness to
the banks family even though the one who
clearly needs help is their PTSD
afflicted neighbor
she'll take on Jane and Michael two
perfectly sweet children who everyone
insists are monsters
I wouldn't stay in this house another
minute not if you adorable well that's
debatable I must say mrs. banks who's
there to show you can be a good mom or
an advocate for women's rights but not
both huh and George the only man in
Hollywood history to hire a beautiful
nanny and have his marriage get better
with Mary's help the children will
literally dick around for 90 minutes
with Burt films Lee's convincing
Englishman I know but show your work
anywhere what as they learn an important
lesson working-class people may be
suffering from poverty in black lung but
they're actually good luck charms and
secretly magic so go ahead and get your
dad fired from his white collar job
he'll sing it off in no time so step in
time with his timeless musical that will
make you forget Disney rip this IP away
from its creator made a film she hated
so much it's in her will that he could
never touch Poppins again then does he
made a movie about her where Walt's the
hero and she's an impossible shrew
responsible is not a work then waited
till she died and made a deal with her
estate for a sequel Chim Chim Cheree
that's mean we play some of the songs we
love like the recently unemployed saw
[Music]
I got sacked tonight will
the sugar code for something song
reality is hard to take
[Music]
well Jinghua super mix you in today
bring down around right now
to spring into your water
[Music]
the one is defending even sayings on
ship chiminey chim chiminey chim chim
the train or D of ductile control
schmate Chim Chim cheroo
worked reduce shock off the pile
children the chimney sweeps are actually
exposed to lethal amounts of carcinogen
song and the 14th syllable words are fun
to say no matter what they mean song
[Music]
starring there's something about mary
joint van joint governor current-day
Dick Van Dyke Garbage Pail Kids doesn't
even get a first name down to Nabi happy
feet the bird lady from home alone to in
the Navy yeah did Mary Pappas just
murder all these old ladies how
whimsical fantastic Brits and how to
mine them
you know the worst thing about living in
a noir D in England all the chimney
sweeps flash bombing on your roof keep
it down you filthy urchins for searches
the ghost of things we ate
you killed my waffles I am an emissary
from hell spider-man you're not fighting
a Honda you're fighting a Honda who won
who's next you decide